light is the connection between us and
the universe through light we can
experience distant stars and look back
at the beginning of existence itself but
what is light in a nutshell light is the
smallest quantity of energy that can be
transported a photon an elementary
particle without a real size that can't
be split only created or destroyed light
also has a wave particle duality being
kind of a particle and a wave at the
same time although this is a lie also
when we say light we actually mean
visible light which is a tiny part of
the electromagnetic spectrum energy in
form of electromagnetic radiation
electromagnetic radiation consists of an
enormous range of wavelengths and
frequencies gamma rays have the smallest
wavelengths because they're the highest
energy photons but most gamma rays are
just under 10 Pico meters which is still
way smaller than a hydrogen atom for
reference a hydrogen atom compared to a
cent is about as big as a cent compared
to the moon visible light is in the
middle of the spectrum in the range of
about 400 nanometers to 700 nanometers
about the size of bacteria on the other
end of the spectrum radio waves can be
up to 100 kilometres in diameter while
the biggest wavelengths we know exist
can span from 10,000 kilometers to a
baffling 100,000 kilometres way larger
than Earth from a physics standpoint all
these different waves are the same they
all have the wave particle duality and
travel at sea the speed of light just at
different frequencies so what makes
visible light so special then well
absolutely nothing we just happen to
have evolved eyes that are good at
registering exactly this part of the
electromagnetic spectrum this is not a
complete coincidence though visible
light is the only set of electromagnetic
radiation that propagates well in water
which happens to be where most eyes
first evolved millions of years ago that
was a smart move because light not only
interacts with matter it's also altered
by it and can be used to gather
information about the world around us
with almost no delay which is arguably
really
helpful for survival okay where does
like come from a vast range of
electromagnetic waves are created when
atoms or molecules dropped from a higher
state of energy to a lower one they lose
energy and emitted in the form of
radiation at the microscopic level
visible light is created when an
electron within an atom that is in an
excited state drops to a lower energy
state and loses this excess energy the
same way incoming light can elevate an
electron to a higher state of energy by
being absorbed by it
microscopically the moving charge of the
electron creates an oscillating magnet
field which creates an oscillating
electric field perpendicular to it these
two fields move themselves through space
transferring energy from one place to
another carrying information about its
place of creation with it why of all the
things in the universe is light the
fastest thing there is let's change the
question what is the fastest way to
travel through space in the universe its
seemed exactly 299,792,458 meters per
second in a vacuum
one billion kilometers per hour
electromagnetic radiation just happens
to move this fast any particle that has
no mass travels at sea without
acceleration or any in-between the light
that's being released from a candle does
not speed up until it reaches light
speed at the very instant of its
creation its speed is C so why is C or
the speed of light finite then well
nobody knows our universe is just built
this way we don't have a smart answer
here so light is a part of a spectrum an
elementary particle that also behaves
like a wave propelled by two
perpendicular fields traveling at the
speed limit of the universe okay that's
nice and all but what about all the
crazy stuff about traveling at the speed
of light and time the twin paradox
quantum stuff whoo things like that we
have to save them for another video for
now let's just be happy that we evolved
eyes that pick up waves of information
permeating need of us making us see
things that help us to put our existence
into perspective
[Music]